i will say this being the first one up
especially early on in the competition
is difficult and i thought y'all did
such a lovely job how are you guys
feeling you made it past the first
elimination
first elimination is intent well how did
you feel about first like those that
music and the waiting for your name
um because my heart was beating like i i
never i get anxious every time 11 years
deep and i'm still i still have anxiety
attacks every day but maybe that's why
you have anxiety because you've been
doing it for so long i i didn't
i was
genuinely happy for the people whose
names were called first
um can you not be such a good person
sorry could you believe could you just
not be
this is the guy that said on instagram
last week if you could just like vote
one time for ten couples split in
between everyone was i was like i do not
approve this message i do not approve
this message
it just didn't seem like that crazy of a
concept but
it to so here was here's my thinking run
okay if you have 10 votes
you're either gonna do put all 10 votes
on one couple that you love or
vote for 10 couples
it's going to continue to dwindle down
and that's just the couples that get the
least amount of votes out of everybody
voting are the ones that go home and
then as the group gets smaller and
smaller i understand divvying up out of
the 10 like okay you know four to this
pers to this couple
six to this couple i understand that but
right now
when there's so many couples going
just literally vote for the ones that
you love that you want to see the most
and then the ones that you don't want to
see are the ones that go home it has
nothing to do with your
uh your talent or your commitment to the
show because everybody's working really
hard doing this
i mean i still don't approve this
message by the way
but it's so sweet yeah that's what makes
us different
um we could talk to you guys each canada
we talked to you guys over the summer
and we asked you know would you guys
dance together and lo and behold here
you are i'm i'm i'm sure it was all of
us we said no we didn't we said no we
lied yeah we didn't see this coming um
i'm gonna put the lying part more on
your on your side just because it feels
better yeah right rude how very dare you
um
you know this wasn't on the radar for us
it was it was not even
from the beginning it wasn't a
conversation we were dancing together i
you know have said a thousand times i
don't mix the two i never have before
this is a very new experience for me and
that was one of the conversations we had
going into it like do we really
can i be balanced in this can i be good
enough to leave the studio at the studio
and home is at home and not mix the two
because that's that's a real thing you
know and it's scary because this isn't
it isn't unknown you know everybody's
like well how is this gonna be and it's
like i i don't know we have no idea i
mean all we can do is strive to do it
the best way that we can
uh but who knows
you know who knows as uh couples are
eliminated and the pressure builds and
all and
and time constraints happen and things
life happens who knows
how it's going to be as of right now
it's it's been working really well and
it's been
we've had we've had definite learning
experiences but that's okay because we
communicate really well and so we get
thrown and there are times when it's
hard and so then we talk about it and
it's
it's a different um
it's a different path to get to the
results for her it's different because
she's used to coming in and she's the
choreographer and it's like
you know listen i
you need to listen to me you need to
deal with your own put that aside we
need to get this done but it's different
with us because
the relationship means as much as it
does that we don't
we we have to walk lightly in some
situations and that's okay but so that's
what we're learning that's what we
didn't know going into this and it's
it's all unknown i've never i've never
done something like this with somebody
that i've dated and she's never dated
anyone that she's danced with before so
this is all new
territory for both of us but we
so far it's been amazing yeah we haven't
had any battles at all and and as bride
just said anything that arises for us we
communicate about i say this is what i'm
struggling with and what i i don't know
how to to balance or manage and he
expresses his feelings on it and nothing
is ever taken personal because we're not
we're not trying to like hide it in a
sense we just talk about it and then
it's resolved and that's also us in our
relationship too it's really healthy and
wonderful so
so yeah we're doing dancing with the
stars together so far it's been great
uh real quick what was your reaction to
finding out about cheryl
devastated for her i watched the video i
uh i told bryce straight away and we
talked about it just devastated for her
it must be scary and awful i'm glad that
she's you know feeling okay um
and she's just basically got to get past
it and hopefully they go they can stay
because cody's so talented yeah and we
can see her come back you know and i
love that the show has found a way to to
really make that happen i think that's
so
beautiful and wonderful and the support
of cheryl and this and we're all with
her and we all definitely missed her
tonight i haven't i haven't been here
obviously as long as sharna has but this
is this is a really amazing group like
it's really i feel like every week
it's it's a very extreme situation
because you know we're not we're not
spending a lot of time together until we
do these live shows yeah so
you so we've had this really
extraordinary bond with with each other
and and so to see
something like that happen you can only
wish for the best for both of them uh
cheryl's been
super kind to me cody's been amazing and
we're all we're all really getting to
know each other so i would hate for
that to end over something uh as silly
as comedy
you